so Chema it's great to see you here on
the carpet for going down tonight
now we haven't asked you this before
we've asked everyone so we can't leave
you out what has been your best death in
the show so far oh my best death oh
that's a great question
oh god poor alfie had to like chop off
that man's head didn't he and then it
wouldn't come off and he had to kick off
like a football I remember him coming
back to the hotel that night go hard
babes by spikes had to kick his head off
and it and he kind of strangely enjoyed
it
I always remember me telling us that you
liked that scene where bran throw
Savalas through the moon door that hole
Oh
oh yes yeah the moon hole of course yeah
that's a bad one yes yeah that's another
good choice damn it hindsight and of
course Lices with her with a boob of
horror took from best death to the man
everyone once dead in the show would
have been your favorite Joffrey moments
so far just gets worse and worse I think
there's something really sinister about
the beginning of season 3 when he's
watching the fight and yesterday Tony
Wei has to drink all that wine there's
something so kind of underlying and
sinister and just you know something is
bubbling he just plays it so well yeah
I'd say that was one of my ones that I
could watch again and just do what a
genius accurate work recently Tresor
Martin said that this possibility of
Game of Thrones movie what do you think
about that and what would you like to
see in it um I think it's a wonderful
idea I mean why not they've made great
production choices so far so it could
only be a good thing
you